until he visits and remains in paradise
until he returns to wherever he came
from. So we ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to forgive him.
[Silence]
All
good
I'm having the the
this is where the sound comes into.
Right. So when I put it here, we're
getting good sound. We're getting good
sound.
[Silence]
We left off
in the narration of
Bkari Muslim
regarding the first revelation of the
Quran to the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
This is the most critical night in his
life and the most critical night for his
with respect to the Quran.
likewise the time and day of his hijra
saiam
and so much happened between these two
times. It's interesting when we look at
the way that the Quran is organized.
The way that the Quran is organized
speaking specifically about the
organization of the chapters of the
Quran.
We have a principle which is a correct
principle and that is that the whole is
greater than the sum of all of its
parts. Right? And the reason for that is
because when I have two gears for
instance and I put them together
that action that is taking place between
those two gears that in itself is also
an additional part. So when we look at
the Quran we see two chapters of the
Quran.
Those are two chapters. But between
those two,
because of the way that the Quran is
organized, there is also more meaning to
be understood. You look at the very
beginning of the prophet's dawah
sallall.aii wasallam the very time first
time he received these these verses of
in the mountain and in the cave of and
then you fast forward to his last three
days on this earth and he was very ill.
He was ill for about 13 days before his
death. Sallallah.aii wasallam and a
couple of days before he passed away in
some narrations it's the morning of that
he passed away of the day that he passed
away he was able to stand and he opened
his hai
after the for was called and Abu Bakr
was in the front and the companions had
straightened their rope rose and they
were preparing to begin their salah.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
looked out at them as they were in this
form
and he smiled and Abu Bakr who thought
that he was coming back out to lead
salah. But he gestured to him and
mechanic
stay there lead the prayer and then he
closed or let the curtains close and
that was the last time his companions
saw him alive sai wasam when you look at
the time between the beginning of this
message and the end it's a very
incredible stark contrast
and the way that the Quran is organized
gives us that contrast.
For instance, we look at
speaking about the conquest of Mecca.
And when you see the people, when you
see humanity and not even just humanity
but the jin too
entering into Islam in droves,
in cues
and then you go to the next chapter
which is
it's almost as if Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is saying to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. This is
where I took you
and this is where we began. This is
where we started with Abuab antagonizing
him and putting out all kinds of
things and saying to him
so we see Allah's victory
and what happened to Abuahab what
happened to Abu Jah what happened to all
the antagonists what happened to all
their plans hands. What happened to all
their plots, all their money, their
wealth, all that sweat and blood that
they put into what happened to all their
propaganda
by the wayside. And what remains is the
word of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But this is where it began. It began in
a time of fear. The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam could have never envisioned
that things would go the way that they
did.
We see that he returned to after hearing
these first five verses.
Recite in the name of your Lord who has
created everything
and created specifically the human being
from a clot a clinging clot of blood.
Now why did Allah choose the term here?
Why did he refer to the beginning of the
human being by this stage in his
development as opposed to any other
stage? We will get to that inshallah.
He says,
"Recite and read and your Lord is the
most
and the epitome of generosity
and he is the paragon of generosity."
Subhanahu Waala.
He is the one who taught
with the pen.
taught the human being what he did not
know.
When he heard these verses,
notice the time between these verses and
that was subsequently revealed after
this. There was a time when Gabriel
didn't return with any new Quran.
And we will get to that at the end of
the narration of Aisha. But we're trying
to kind of set the stage here. We're
kind of trying to make sure that we
see the full picture of the beginning of
this revelation. And why these five
verses specifically? Why? Of all the
verses of the Quran, these five
these five and these five verses marked
the beginning of his prophethood. For
this reason, the scholars say
he was made a prophet when he received
and he was then elevated and appointed a
messenger when Allah sent down to him.
And there is a difference between a
prophet and a messenger.
Now he went back to Khadijah. He was
shaking. Aisha described his
Aisha described his disturbance and his
shock. She said
his heart of hearts was shaking, was
trembling.
His hands and his legs, his limbs were
shaking. And he went back to and said,
"Cover me. Cover me." And so he was
swaddled, but he also said, "Pour water
on me." So he's hot and cold at the same
time, simultaneously. This is shock.
This is what is referred to in modern
medicine as the fight or flight
response. He is got this adrenaline
surging through his veins and he is
trying to make sense of all of the
things that just happened to him. And he
told Khadijah what happened.
And he told her not only what happened
in the cave, but he also told her about
the premonitions he's been having when
he's seeing premonitions in his sleep.
And they're playing out exactly
vividly as if it was the real world,
which it was. These were prophet pro
these were prophecies that he was
receiving. And so
and he said
I am terrified for myself. What does
this mean? He was terrified for himself.
Some scholars mention that he feared
that this was his death that he was
experiencing death.
Whilst others like
mentions in his explanation of this
narration that he was fearing before
when he was seeing these premonitions
and when he was experiencing these odd
things that were happening that this was
actually from a shaitan and that he
might be starting to be affected by a
shaitan or what is referred to as you
know starting to lose his grasp on
reality. But this doesn't mean that he
was ever confused as to who came to
visit him. He could never confuse the
words of Allah with the words of aan or
the words of
with the words of other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So he understood
what was happening but he feared that he
would not be able to fulfill what he had
been appointed for and he wouldn't be
able to cont
commanded him with. So he was
terrified. He was terrified that he
received this message and he doesn't
feel he is going to be able to
carry it, that he's going to be able to
bear it, that he is going to be able to
be that conduit of revelation between
Allah and us.
And so
reminded him of who he is and reminded
him of who Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is.
She said,
She said, "No, I swear by Allah, Allah
would never humiliate you. He would
never humiliate you. Give you a message
that you can't bear, take your life and
take your sanity in such a way. Allah
would never do this to you. Why? Why
would Allah not do this to him?" She
said and she mentioned five traits. She
said,
[Silence]
"So she said, "Allah would never
humiliate you. Of all of the people, you
he would never humiliate." Why? She
said, "Because you keep ties with your
kin
and because you carry the burden of
those who are unable to bear their own
burden. And you help to achieve for
those who are unable to achieve for
themselves, the poor, the the meek, the
weak. You are the one that completes
those who are incomplete.
And you respect and honor your guest
with the utmost of generosity.
And there is no
avenue of truth that you are not its
vanguard and victor.
And so these are your traits. Allah
would never
humiliate a man of such traits. and
character. Now notice what she's saying.
She has this image of who Muhammad is
saiam
and she has this image and idea of who
Allah is that Allah is not someone that
rewards
generosity with stinginess. He
doesn't reward gratitude with rejection.
He doesn't reward good with bad. Now,
how does Khadijah know this?
Based on what?
Well, this takes us to a very
interesting point which we will end with
tonight that I think many of us have not
really contemplated.
We go to the first verse of the first
verses of surah al bakar.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Allah says that this Quran is a guidance
for the righteous.
A guidance for the righteous. Okay. Who
is righteous?
The ones who learn righteousness from
the Quran. And who is the Quran for? The
righteous. So what does that mean? It's
a it's kind of a cir it's what we refer
to as in rhetoric as a circular
reasoning. It's a it's a circular
reasoning. Meaning that these two traits
feed off of each other. The Quran
teaches righteousness.
But who are the ones that learn
righteousness from the Quran? The
righteous. And so the more righteous you
are, the more you learn righteousness.
And the more you learn righteousness,
the more you become righteous.
But if we take it all the way back to
the very very beginning when a person
first accepts the Quran,
is he righteous in that?
Yes, he is righteous by accepting the
Quran at the very first.
And so that righteousness is from the
Quran. But the Quran is also teaching
righteousness
by those who are righteous. So what does
that mean? The scholars tell us of them
that righteousness here
one of the meanings that is meant by
righteousness are those who uphold the
truth even before they know about Islam.
Now pay attention to this. We are, you
and I, every human being, we have been
created upon what? The fra
the
predisposition.
We generally know in a macro sense
lying is wrong, truthfulness is good,
stealing is bad.
being honest is good, murder is
wrong, harming others unrightfully is
wrong. We have this naturally
before we hear from the prophets and
messengers.
And so what kind of person is most prone
to accepting the message of the
prophets?
That is those who follow what little
truth they already have inside them.
Those who follow and adhere to what
little conscience
they already have
before they learn righteousness from the
Quran. Right? And the companions said as
much. They said as much that we learned
eman and then Allah sent down the Quran
and we learned the Quran and we learned
eman from the Quran.
Meaning that a person they've never
heard of a prophet or messenger but they
know
beyond reason that lying is wrong and so
they don't lie.
This choice to adhere to what little
truth they already have is what leads
them finally to the path of the prophets
and messengers.
And those who reject the prophets and
messengers are those who have rejected
that truth that they knew before they
even knew what the prophets and
messengers were. And for this reason,
Allah said,
regarding the Quran. Those who believe
in the hereafter, they believe in the
Quran.
They believe in the hereafter. They
believe in the Quran because they did
not reject logic and fra because of how
they want to live their life. They have
this internal struggle between
morality
and desire
and they choose their morality. Maybe
not every time but mostly they are a
person who values the truth.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us the type of people that reject the
Quran. And we'll end with this. He said,
[Silence]
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala. And we will
turn their hearts and and sight away
from it, away from the miracles. They
will look up, see the moon split in
half,
and then they'll turn around and at the
very first when they first see it,
they're in shock Pharaoh was when
he first saw.
And they'll say, "Wow, it's a
strike of lightning goes through their
heart. This man has to be a messenger.
He is a prophet." But then as it wears
off and the shock goes away and the
novelty wears off and they go back home
and they're in their comfy bed and
they're getting their manicures and
they're relaxed and they're in their
environment that they made just how they
want. They start to reason why he's not
a messenger. No, no, no. That was
actually a magic trick. No, that was
sorcery. No, that was some kind of no
way. Right. And this is the struggle.
But Allah says, "We will turn their
hearts and their sight away from it.
They'll neither be able to accept it nor
even see the truth anymore for what it
is, just as they rejected the truth the
first time when they stepped onto that
path of rejection.
and we will leave them in their blunder
and misguidance
going to and fro unable to find their
way through the darkness. We will end
with this. We will continue this
inshallah in our next sitting. We
will finish up this story and then we
will begin the of these verses before we
move on to
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
which is